it's it's it's quite simple you know
when a pit bull bites
people doesn't let go no it has now been
what are we going on
five months and the democrats will not
stop talking about january 6
and the republicans how often have they
brought up minneapolis
never one one thing we should actually
throw out you know today is actually the
anniversary of david dorn
right and i i did not see and i you know
maybe i just didn't see it but
i don't remember any of republican
leadership or uh
anyone who's been on the sort of you
know quote unquote black the blue
side say anything about that you know i
i ran the fundraiser for his family when
that took place
you know we did all we did everything
for that and this was not something
where you you had anybody today's the
one year anniversary but when it was the
one year anniversary of george floyd
that's the only thing the democrats they
flew they flew the black lives matter
flags at embassies
the story we had out on human events and
the story of david dorn is that he was a
retired police captain who heard an
alarm go off at his friend's store and
went to go check it out and someone put
a bullet in his chest
yeah i wanted to steal a tv and the film
is brutal the live stream it live stream
so he yeah he
he he ends up dying on facebook live and
a guy was like
a guy's yelling like all that for a tv
man meanwhile
you get the complicated story of george
floyd which is
complicated at the very in the in the
best case it's
it's absolutely hard to break through
david dorn was a good guy
a model citizen someone we could look up
to and when that you know and i i did
get the opportunity to speak with his
wife early on and made sure that you
know we had her blessing obviously
before we did the fundraiser so it's
worked her
at length um before she came out and
spoke at some of the conventions and did
some of the advocacy work that she's
done which has been fantastic
but you know she told us these stories
that you know he would go out and he
would drive by the shop every once in a
while one of the reasons
um that he cared about the shop so much
that's actually the place
that it had been on his beat when he was
when he was a patrol officer
and so he had responded the things there
in the past it had been something that
he just sort of came up with
in st louis and that's actually the shop
they run a jewelry shop there as well
that's where he got the engagement ring
for his wife you know what it's not just
uh it's it's not just the republican
politicians
look at what the left does for george
floyd look at what the the corporations
do for george floyd
the republicans should be should be
passing a bill saying today should be
david dornday
they should be putting up david dorn
flags they should be they should be
doing everything
and more the left has done for george
floyd but for for david dorn the problem
is the anvil is not hot for them
so if they try to mimic it's kind of
like the the democrats
whoever shooting downhill if they try
that same tactic no no no
it's not about mimicking them it's about
making your own space creating your own
culture
making making and saying you know what
democrats if you don't want to be
involved in the conversation we don't
care because we
respect david dorn and we're sad for his
loss the problem is
it's the media that's heating up the
whole um
chauvin you know so ignore them
conservative media
keeps responding to the left's narrative
the media comes out and says
here's our story and the conservatives
then respond to instead of doing their
own work
but for in order for the the republican
politicians to get that done they would
need media presence that would be like
david doran david
no they wouldn't remember david dornan
people would win that being said though
you know the question i think what
you're really talking about is critical
mass right
and i think that at this point
there is enough of a critical mass of
independent media which thrives through
social media like this podcast right
here
where you do now have this separate
space
which you can inject these cultural
stories these icons david doran isn't it
is a a cultural icon we got a picture of
him and
for for you know i actually saw that
someone drew it for us
and that's that as someone who was and
and everyone who spoke about him a
pillar of his community
you know got people off the street in
some cases got them into the police
force served the community
that's all he wanted to do that was his
whole life right um
didn't didn't even wake his wife up when
he when he went out that night because
he knew what was going on in st louis
and he knew she probably would have said
don't go
and he knew he was going to go anyway
right this this is the type of per
that's the type of hero
right that that i want to teach my boys
about that i want to teach my kids about
you know you look at david dorn this is
a guy who's a hero right not not lebron
james not you know some of these other
celebrities who are out there shooting
their mouth off about stuff that they've
never even looked into
right someone who serves their community
who serves others and in this case
made the ultimate sacrifice that's a
hero think about david dorn's behavior
the left is angry about police they say
are are brutal
or too scared david dorne was a police
officer he retired
and when he went to that pawn shop did
he show up shaking and quiving with a
gun
shooting wildly at civilians or whatever
like the left would claim the cops do
no no so he certainly seemed like he was
a good cop because when he went to this
pawn shop
he didn't go in guns ablaze and he
wasn't freaking out and he lost his life
because someone thought the tv was more
valuable
so there there's every reason this man
should be celebrated by the left but
they don't care
and i think conservatives by the way
working class
yeah absolutely yeah i think too many
conservatives have make the mistake of
assuming
that the left operates on the same moral
foundation in the world framework as
they do
and that a sound argument will resonate
with these people no either they don't
care
they relish in the destruction or they
just want power so when someone like
david dorn loses their life
oh they're not going to say two words
about it when the republicans do what
does the media say
they're just trying to to own the libs
by by doing the same thing and
it's not the same thing we're talking
about a system and blah blah blah right
but so
when you're talking about and this isn't
necessarily a moral question in this
case but we're talking about the
framework of these things
and critical mass to take it back to the
original story that we spoke about at
the top of this
the lab leak theory right this was
something where we were told very early
on
you can't talk about this this is
debunked this is not real
this is not a thing and yet there was a
cadre of independent media
that never let go of this they were a
pit bull when it came to that story they
didn't let go of it and it finally broke
through because enough people
sat down and a lot of it has to do with
you know there's all these sort of like
you know think pieces now well you know
it really is interesting that it came
around
at this point it's almost like something
happened and going from 2020 into 2021
that we can now talk about it right it
is clear like trump isn't around anymore
and this was
this was the pro-trump you know kind of
stance at the time
uh that he took and you just didn't want
to say trump was right that's the reason
people are talking about it now but it's
also because
so many people for the past year and a
half would not let this go
they knew the facts were on their side
and they were a thorn in the side of
this narrative
all the way through to the point where
of course it broke through
and that's why you're seeing now even in
public opinion polls you're seeing it
spiking high
40s almost 50 percent are saying look i
think this came out of that lab
yeah there was it was a medium article
that started reigniting the the
um this is nicholas wade so there's a
former the former new york times
scientist couldn't even get in the
mainstream press had to write it on
medium
and then finally it breaks through but
it it it is absolutely
uh i i do think the work of buzzfeed
contributed i think they knew the foyers
were coming
you know um the the fouchy did the
government did and
many of the journalists were like these
emails are going to get really sooner or
later
and i wonder if they were like we'll
release them and what does buzzfeed do
totally positive narrative fauci was
just fighting to keep
you know give us a sound you know keep
controlled situation and then you read
the emails and you're like
this is crazy but the media's framing of
it cnn wapo
and and buzzfeed here's the emails
leaked and fauci is a great and good man
so here's here's the real question and
this gets back to the other american
greatness article you were talking about
if we have so the divisions in america
yes there's there's there's an urban
royal
rural division i can't talk anymore for
some reason
forever i'm i'm i'm out here talking in
different ways
yeah um but um so we now have a division
that can be
neighbor to neighbor right that it
doesn't necessarily matter where you are
it matters who you're listening to
what you're listening to bro bro down
the street there's two houses
yeah one that's all rainbows and one
that's all trump oh nice next door to
each other
each other yeah and that's you know and
that gets that reminds me of these these
stories that you hear about
when from the civil war and they talk
about you know brother versus brother
father versus son
and you think like well i would i would
never turn against my brother's my
brother i would never return against my
father
you know we might disagree with our turn
against him and then you sort of look at
some of these divisions now and you say
and and the look at the way that
families have split up over this stuff
i um i'll just say it right i had people
that did
in my family that didn't want to come to
my wedding because they were convinced
they were convinced that the woman i was
marrying was a russian spy
because she was born in the soviet union
not not even russia
phobia one of the former you know the
former satellite countries they would
call them now
but they were convinced because they are
msnbc watchers and they are convinced
that that's that's that's what was going
on
here's this trump guy and this immigrant
girl from the wrong part of the world
and well she must be you know she must
be one of them and
and i don't say that to like own them or
anything that's sad i just think i
think the whole situation is that i i'd
rather have politics be put
aside and i'd just like to have my
family back right you know
yeah we can talk about star wars or
something or whatever the latest
superman movie is like
batman versus robin which is quite good
actually thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time